la rue des plantes heureusement
seulement des moutons mais trente ans
qu'ils attendent les plongeurs la honte
le jardin des plantes c'est là-bas tout
droit et il ya des pompiers la bonne
premier jour des crues le canal
d'orléans déborde à chécy les 150
maisons situées entre ce cours d'eau et
la levée de la loire sont prises au
piège
la rue des plantes est totalement
submergé les pompiers du loiret évacuent
les habitants en bateau dans la rue
plusieurs personnes sont sauvés in
extremis les voisins rio secours l'eau
montait une vitesse fulgurante et on a
vu que le volume d'eau était tellement
important que les personnes en mes
voisins ne savent pas nager
des gens qu'on 85 ans 90 ans l'eau
arrivait au dessus du premier étage et
les gens aller se réfugier dans les
greniers pour éviter en fait de se noyer
malheureusement ce n'était pas la bonne
solution ils ont pas eu le temps de
s'enfuir arlette et andré sont sous le
choc
leur maison est située juste sous la
levée de la loire j'ai une voisine qui
m'a appelé au téléphone vers 9h30 et
elle me dit viens vite viens vite d'aidé
vient vite j'ai la loire qui est dans
mon jardin
tous vivent tellement bien là tu perds
tout on perd tous là
le pc de crise est installée dans une
salle communale une bouée de secours
pour virginie et son mari cette venue de
voilà le lieu où sont tous se retrouvent
avec les voisins où on s'entraide où on
se dit voilà comment on va s'organiser
il ya la solidarité et ça c'est ça nous
fait tenir beaucoup parce que c'est
quand même difficile émotionnellement
quand on nous apporte et puis qu'on
découvre de carreaux le chaos total dans
la salle à côté des vêtements des
produits de première nécessité que sont
venus chercher bernard et annie j'ai
toujours le même plus loin vers tala va
faire 26° le vert y aller la love avoir
des badges bon j'espère que pas point
effet nous emmène en barque
c'est toute une vie qui par toute une
région moi j'ai 63 ans j'ai pour la rue
des plantes a été décrété en zone
d'exclusion par le maire les habitants
ne peuvent pas accéder à leurs maisons
vont rentrer chez moi pour les
médicaments
pour les bambins le périmètre est bouclé
et surveillé jour et nuit par la police
les pompiers militaires de brignoles
spécialisés dans les catastrophes
naturelles sont à pied d'oeuvre pour une
opération de grande envergure vider les
poches de rétention et évacuer l'eau
dans le canal
dans un premier temps on a mis en place
une pompe de grande capacité
un débit d'environ 750 mètres cubes
heures donc c'est un terrain assez
particulier parce qu'on a un recoupement
des eaux qui se font en début de
lotissement donc pour nous la priorité
c'est du déjà d'implanter ce type de
pompe pour voir déjà évacué le maximum
de dos qui a aux alentours de du
lotissement les pompiers progresse d'à
présent maison par maison
mais un deuxième danger se profile
nous avons repéré dans nos observations
quotidiennes quasi heure par heure des
mouvements terrain des puits defanti des
billets etc et donc avant de pouvoir
retourner sur le terrain tant avec des
interventions que pour les habitants il
faut absolument qu'on sécurise le lieu
un expert du bureau de recherches
géologiques et minières est à l'oeuvre
rue des plantes en une semaine 40
effondrements ont été comptabilisés dans
la région au lieu de 4 par an
habituellement sur cette commune a un
rapport avec la loire le problème à la
base et pas dans ces allusions le
problème vient de plus bas de ce
calcaire dans lequel la loire a creusé
son unique est truffé de ces cavités qui
ont des diamètres plus ou moins grands
qui viennent ensuite c'est l'explication
qu'on en a ici qui viennent ensuite
aspirer les alluvions qui sont juste au
dessus et la propriétaire de la maison
on n'est pas au bout de ses peines il
m'a confirmé que le cabanon allez allez
tomber à les suivre et probablement la
haie de thuyas qui nous appartient mais
peut-être aussi derrière
en attendant de pouvoir rentrer chez eux
arlette et andré ont trouvé refuge chez
des amis à c'était le premier geste on
va aller les chercher
elle m'a déjà téléphoné mais moi j'ai
pas osé dire j'ai dit coup ton monte
la page en jeu semble qu'on va voir
comment ça se passe dans ben ali ils
nous ont attribué des lits de camp et on
les a vus arriver
j'ai eu pas d'envié pas dormir c'est pas
que c'est pas bien
non mais on a une chambre depuis dix
jours peu à peu chacun prend ses marques
et arlette tient à préparer le repas
mais l'attenté de moins en moins
supportable
là c'est long quand ce combat bruit
qu'est-ce que comment on va faire
qu'est-ce qu'il ya de casser qu'est-ce
qu'il n'y a pas de case et aa hamon ou
encore les factures avons nous encore
ceci points wii et de ça tourne dans ma
tête tourne
vous serez nouvelle réunion au pc de
crise la situation se débloque enfin les
sinistrés de la rue des plantes vont
pouvoir retourner dans leurs maisons
d'accord donc il ya que vous et les
secours les interventions qui peuvent
circuler dans la rue donc si toutefois
vous voyez une circulation qui est pas
de cette nature là vous nous prévenez
immédiatement pour que les forces de
l'ordre puissent intervenir
je viens de récupérer mon laisser-passer
pour accéder aux 42 bis rue des plantes
contre remise d'une pièce d'identité et
de la carte grise du véhicule
à la salle jean sait strictement rien
moi moi j'ai rencontré mon compteur et
rien ne marche
non non ça ne faut pas en plus et andré
n'est pas au bout de ses surprises
voyez le tracteur là bas il l'est sous
un appentis à 30 50 m il est musclé la
rochelle on est dans les congèle à
messieurs par contre tout l'immeuble
nous avons pris un coup
car tu es là celui là je pense qu on le
récupère armes nous on était tranquille
là mais je pense que quand il y aura de
l'aide laura bleu puis tranquille
[Musique]
un peu plus haut dans la rue la maison
de virginie est méconnaissable
c'est pas évident quand on ouvre sa
porte et puis que ben voilà on découvre
des combinaisons comme ça ici l'eau est
montée à 1 mètre 50 en moins d'une heure
et se pose la question de l'avenir dans
cette maison que le couple avait
entièrement restaurée ma fille cessons
pleyel callas commencé à jouer du piano
quand elle dit que petit on a essayé de
le frapper mais en une heure de temps
c'était c'était pas possible c'était
beaucoup trop lourd puis voilà voilà
voilà ce qui reste de notre maison donc
c'est un petit peu difficile mais en
même temps on est là on a réussi à
sortir avec beaucoup d'eau mais
maintenant ce qu'on a besoin de savoir
c'est si la maison va tenir aussi
engagées elles vont passer on va savoir
si elles sont réparables ou si
malheureusement mais c'est aussi nous
faut qu'elles soient rasés on a on a de
la famille on a des amis faut relever
pour lever les bras
essayer de se réparer tout au bout de la
rue des plantes la maison d'amis et
bernard construite il ya seulement cinq
ans le couple mesure le désastre sa
tournoyer c'est un tsunami
car dès l'été
c'est pareil dans ma chambre
on n'a pas d'eau t'as même pas
essayé de m'apprendre le blouson la
trace de l'eau mais c'est quelque chose
qu'ils s'amendent pas là j'ai des
enfants je peux pas rester chez les
enfants avis il y en a pour un an ici
travaux ombre je ne sais pas je ne sais
plus c'est vrai qu'on s'est vus on a
travaillé toute notre vie on a eu ça
donc
on avait ça et puis après ça on n'a plus
rien et puis puis de ma ça sera un jour
nous faut le prendre avec philosophie
comme ça
la rue des plantes n'a pas fini de
panser ses plaies
à quelques mètres de là le canal a
regagné son lit et la loire s'étale
majestueuse comme s'il ne s'était rien
passé